hoy 1º de diciembre se conmemora el día
internacional de la lucha contra el sida
la campaña conjunta de la opc y onusida
este año 2021 está basada en el lema
poner fin a la desigualdad poner fin al
sida y poner fin a las pandemias en esta
jornada entonces se busca comunicar
sobre la importancia del acceso
equitativo a servicios de salud y el
fortalecimiento también de las acciones
en el primer nivel de atención en
especial para la prevención del vih y
los servicios de tratamiento contra esta
enfermedad contra este virus este virus
pero lamentablemente estamos lejos de
acabar con el sida en el año 2030 esto
es uno de los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible de la onu que será amenazado
por otra pandemia la adecco bit 19 la ms
también alertó de preocupante número de
infecciones del virus de
inmunodeficiencia humana no
diagnosticados en europa debido a un
menor número de pruebas por cuenta del
coronavirus vamos a salvar entonces a
nuestra primera mitad ya la doctora
alejandra corado directora regional del
programa junto de naciones unidas sobre
el vih/sida onusida para américa latina
y el caribe gracias doctora por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 que tenga usted un muy buen
día y le pregunto entonces que tanto ha
cambiado el mundo cuarenta años después
de detectarse los primeros casos de vih
le pido entonces que nos dé un balance
muchísimas gracias primero por esta
invitación es por en este caso poner el
tema en la agenda sobre todo
considerando que el consell va a llevar
a los últimos 18 meses yo quiero ser
positiva positiva en el sentido que
gracias a la lucha activa por allá nos
da en la década de los 80 de las
personas que vivían con vih sin lugar a
dudas hemos aumentado la cobertura de
tratamiento y eso es una buena noticia
el que tengamos en este momento es cerca
de 28.2 millones de personas con acceso
al tratamiento es una buena noticia y es
un gran avance considerando que para el
2003 por ejemplo no llegaba ni siquiera
a 5 millones de personas en tratamiento
esa es una buena noticia es una buena
noticia que la mayor parte de los países
financien sus respuestas al vih es una
buena noticia que cada vez más las
pruebas son gratuitas en muchos de los
países es una buena noticia que la
transmisión maternoinfantil se esté
controlando en muchos países y que cada
vez nacen menos niños que llevan con vih
es una buena noticia que cada vez más
que se disminuyan los países que tengan
leyes que restrinjan el acceso por
persona personas con vih esas son buenas
noticias sin embargo como tú bien decías
hay muchísimas brechas y tenemos que
alcanzadas y tenemos que alcanzar las
brechas el mensaje del día de hoy pone
el final al el vih por el final las
pandemias y poner fin a las
desigualdades no lo dicen las
desigualdades que en este momento son
las principales barreras porque estamos
dejando atrás a muchas personas estamos
dejando atrás a las personas que
pertenecen a las poblaciones claves
sabemos que los hombres que tienen sexo
con hombres con hombres gays mujeres
trans trabajadores sexuales usuario de
drogas siguen infectándose con vih
siguen muriendo por causas relacionadas
del sida aún cuando existe tratamiento
para ellas entonces en este momento esa
es una brecha que tenemos que alcanzar
sabemos que existen personas en
comunidades rurales en comunidades
indígenas mujeres adolescentes y niñas
que no están teniendo acceso a servicios
personas en comunidades rurales en
ciudades muchas veces a dos horas de
grandes ciudades que no están teniendo
acceso al tratamiento entonces esa es la
principal brecha sabemos que sigue
habiendo estigma y discriminación que
siguen muriendo
por pertenecer a esas poblaciones clave
ahí es donde tenemos que poner la mirada
doctora alejandra vamos a la parte
social usted lo acaba de mencionar el
estigma y la discriminación
cómo está esto en este año 2021 ya 40
años después sigue habiendo estigma y
también discriminación a las personas
infectadas con vih que nada tiene que
ver con su desarrollo social y que por
supuesto pues todavía hay gente que no
quiere compartir el trabajo con ellos
que no quiere compartir no sea un vaso
de agua dar la mano que evidentemente
así no es la manera de contagio de vih
absolutamente sigue habiendo este una
discriminación hacia las personas que
viven con vih y las personas que están
en riesgo de infectarse con vih como son
las poblaciones claves motrices me gusta
nombrarlas porque es importante
nombrarlos los hombres que las mujeres
trans las trabajadoras sexuales los
usuarios de droga sigue viendo este mi
discriminación y es muy importante
recordar que esa es la principal barrera
para la prevención del vih que para
reducir las muertes asociadas al sida
sigue habiendo estigma discriminación en
todos los espacios y es importante
entender que si una persona no tiene
acceso a un trabajo digno porque se pide
una prueba de vih como requisito para
trabajar esa persona no va a poder tener
recursos para alimentarse y poder
recibir un tratamiento adecuado si una
persona se le limita el acceso a la
educación esa persona no va a poder
formarse no va a poder tener un trabajo
directo no va a poder mantener a su
familia el estigma y discriminación
siguen los servicios de salud y eso es
que lo que limita que muchas mujeres
trans que muchas trabajadoras sexuales
sigan este o puedan realmente tener
acceso a estos servicios
emocionalmente cómo afecta esta
enfermedad a los portadores del vih
emocionalmente sigue siendo una
enfermedad este que a muchas personas
les causa muchísimo dolor sin que
tuviera que ser así por otro lado
también el activismo es maravilloso y
las personas que viven con vih muchas de
ellas ayer lo declaraba una activista en
la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas les ha salvado la vida porque les
permite unirse a una comunidad de
activistas y luchar por una causa común
que realmente hermosa pero si el
aislamiento el rechazo por sus familias
el rechazo por sus comunidades sigue
siendo muchísimo estragos en personas en
las que sabemos que podrían tener una
vida de lo vivido 80 a 90 años es tener
un trabajo digno tener hijos tener
nietos este porque existe el tratamiento
para ello si no existiera el estigma
discriminación